so you believe in Prophet Muhammad you
believe in his book you believe in Quran
I don't believe in Quran again that's
the wrong way of putting it these are
not things to believe in they are
signposts to the thing to believe in
scripture as sacred history is the
attempt by individuals who have
confronted an extraordinary
extraordinary experience
and who have using the limited means at
their disposal
attempted to record that uh
extraordinary experience often in Poetic
and symbolic language deep meaningful
mystical language so that they can
preserve it for generations to
understand so you're also a matter of
Faith so you're also man of Faith okay
so to you your the risk you're taking is
I'm risking believing the Quran not the
Bible that's your risk right I mean
faith is believing in something you have
not yet seen there's a lot of criticism
on the book of Quran there's a lot of
criticism on the Muslim religion a lot
of criticism on the religion you
represent your risk is I think after
life is my bet is I'm going to take the
route of uh uh being a Muslim versus I
see where you're coming yeah I'm sorry
when you study the religions of the
world
it becomes impossible to take any one of
these religions all that seriously and
there's two reasons for it one because
you instantly recognize the religious
patterns the sort of a phenomena that
they all have in common with each other
that they're all saying basically the
same thing and more importantly they're
saying it kind of in the same way right
A lot of the same myths are just kind of
repurposed the myth of Jesus's
resurrection is just the myth of mithras
Resurrection right the shraushant in uh
in Zoroastrianism is a salvific
character uh whose mother magically gets
impregnated and gives birth to a
Messianic figure who brings in the end
of the world that's a thousand years
before Jesus right I mean these are just
the same stories over and over and over
again
however
they are interlinked
in the sense that they are trying to
express something that has a person of
faith I believe is real
and that is that there is something
beyond the material realm there is a
real Transcendent reality beyond the
physical world but it's faith faith so
it's a risk it's absolutely okay so the
risk so there's a part of me that's
sitting here listening to you for the
first hour
you sound more atheist than you sound
muslim okay you sound more atheist you
definitely don't sound Christian
obviously you're given the arguments of
atheists it's like I'm listening to uh
uh Chris Hitchens debate his brother
uh uh or I'm listening to an atheist
give their argument that's the part so
that kind of comes back to saying well
why do you choose to be a Muslim why do
you choose to follow the Quran if you're
such a scholar and you're educated and
you got these four degrees shouldn't an
educated man like yourself who's dealing
a lot on facts not risk believing any
religion and rather just be an atheist
you are you in a minute ago you just
said that when you look at any of the
world religions that there's there's
flaws and there's issues and they and
there's lunacies and then there's
repeated myths so how did you choose one
rather than just being a very scholar of
the fake question yeah say hey I'm the
scholar of the fake here's all my books
I'm going to delve into certain
characters Baskerville and others like
this
but you know what no I'm going to stop
and I'm going to choose one how do you
get there so yeah this is a great
question first of all let's try to rid
our minds of these categories like
atheist Muslim well if you're you're
clearly not a Christian because you
question certain aspects of the Bible
[ __ ] there are hundreds of millions
of Christians who would agree with
everything that I just said and would I
mean priests the priests who taught me
these things right they're not just
Christians they've given their life
they're dedicated their entire life to
be fair a lot of things are weird hope
is saying certain things right now that
the Catholic Church wouldn't have agreed
with 20 years ago but and Catholics
unfortunately have to be are forced to
agree with them not forced just because
no because he's not going to
excommunicate when I say forced if you
want to be part of the church and the
Pope says it oh my God I'm either gonna
have to leave my rituals that I've been
living for the last 48 years and go be a
non-denominational go be something else
or just say defend the pope just to be
clear that's only if the pope uh
threatens this communication if the Pope
says this is now belief and if you don't
believe it then you are excommunicated
then yes you're forced to believe it but
the pope doesn't do any of that stuff
and the pope is Christian and so if he's
not of not of not a different kind of a
Christian today than 20 or 30 years ago
okay there is no such thing as
Christianity let's start there there is
no such thing as Islam there is no such
thing as Judaism there is no such thing
as Buddhism there is only Christianity's
buddhisms Islams
Christianity is whatever a Christian
says it is Buddhism is whatever a
Buddhist says it is there is no
mechanism for me to say you call
yourself a Buddhist okay but you don't
believe this interpretation of the
person is what you're saying you're not
really a Buddhist so let's let's start
there that's the important thing the
second thing that I think is really
important to understand is that religion
all religions
are far less a matter of beliefs and
practices than they are a matter of
identity and that's true of every
religion in the world and every part of
the world seventy percent of Americans
call themselves Christian [ __ ]
[ __ ] 70 of Americans follow the
teachings of Christ seventy percent of
Americans go to church on you know
Sunday 70 of Americans read the Bible on
a consistent basis the vast majority of
that 70 percent when they say I am
Christian they are not making a faith
statement they're making an identity
statement and that is true of it
Buddhists and Jews and Muslims that what
we people on the outside tend to do is
think that religion is just about the
things that you believe and if you don't
believe what the mainstream believes
then you're not really that thing
anymore I don't disagree with that I'm
with you there on the identity party
to the question there's some
fundamentals here right and when if if a
person says I'm a Muslim or a person
says I'm a Christian you you dive into
it a little bit and you
more often than not you're going to find
some world view creep in where they've
made their own designation when you take
a look at the 70 of people in America
that say they're a Christian there's
only about 15 percent of those that have
what you would call a Biblical worldview
and these are not the Amish in the
middle of Pennsylvania adopting nothing
of modern technology these are people
that have an authentic biblical
worldview and at the same thing there's
people that say well I'm Jewish well now
wait a minute are you a Zionist as a
political State Jew or are you authentic
so I think identity is like you're
correct about it but we need to kind of
wash that a little bit because I can say
I'm a southerner oh sorry sorry listen
I'm I'm sorry I'm a Bostonian what is a
Bostonian I'm sorry I'm a New Englander
we have all these labels do you know
what we just kind of take it as it is
I'm a midwesterner right you have all
labels that happen all over the place
and you can't take a broad brush and
just sweep everything out Reza because
you're correct about the 70 you are
correct about the 70 percent
he said but within that there are people
that do have a Biblical worldview
whether they be Jews whether they be
Muslims whether they be Christians there
are those are they the real Christians
because they have the biblical worldview
and and the other 45 aren't I think well
you know what a cleric would tell you
that it is my job and I'll speak to your
faith that it is my job to ensure that I
teach and I help people to calibrate
what is the authenticity of their Muslim
faith and the principles and tendencies
and who gave him that job
he went to school and he learned a bunch
of things and now well he also has he
also has the scripture that they have
and he can either choose I have that
same scripture that's exactly right you
can be north of London and you can be a
radical cleric what I don't want to the
two what I don't want to do is the
following here's what I don't want to do
by the way there's there's angles I can
take with Virgin Mary in the Quran and
what uh you know the Quran says about
Virgin Mary and what many Muslims think
about Virgin Mary and we can go that
angle but the part I was going to go
with you on the Virgin Mary side that
even in the Quran they talk about is the
chances of somebody being born because
you know a lot of people made that claim
back in the days because it's
embarrassing oh my God you know you're
having sex on you know prior to this
prior to getting married and then for
the chances of that sun ending up being
Jesus that's a one in a trillion type of
a number that's just a very random
method I'm a math guy very random
mathematical number to come up with that
so the faith part with that is
it's tough to kind of fight against that
part but let me let me come back because
the question was still not answered yeah
let me let me come back to the question
so if your arguments I'm listening to
you
you're very critical of the Christian
church in a very non-critical way the
way you're doing it is a a way a scholar
would do it uh where
uh the the average person listens to
that and they say oh my God what do I
say to this part here but I'll flip it
and I'll say dude you sound like an
atheist and I can respect that if you're
an atheist you're an atheist if you're
gonna say look my risk I'm taking a life
I'm taking a risk that quran's the book
I'm not taking the risk that I'm going
to be a Christian I'm taking a risk I
want to be a Muslim no problem let's get
past this part I'm going to go to the
next part on question if you want to
answer the atheist part you will answer
this well here in a minute but here's
what I want you to be thinking about
um how do you judge a great parent
how do you judge a great parent by their
actions
by their actions Yeah by how they raise
their the things that they do that's how
I judge every person okay things that
you do is it fair for me to judge you
based on
like if I see you
my imagination I've never met your mom
I've never met you that this is our
first interaction to get us to the
audience so we've never had dinner
together I don't know your story except
for what I've read right
I see a part of you that's your dad and
I see a part of you that's your mom I
see the rebel in your dad okay where
he's a rebellious guy and he's I see the
atheist arguments of your dad when I'm
listening to you okay but then I see
also your loyalty for your mom's side
and then your own independence where I'm
gonna go take my ride and here's what I
come up with listen Mom Dad salute you
on this side pop salute to your mom on
this side my dad never fails to remind
me that Khomeini was a big mistake he
called it right you talk about that
regularly
but if we're going to judge a product
based on its parents
product parents parents good job you
raise a good citizen he's done well for
himself right
I think it's also fair to judge a
religion based on what it produces okay
based on what it produces so let's let's
go away from uh uh I've sat and debated
with guys who know every single
scripture in the Bible but nobody
follows them they're very small and I've
sat and talked to people that are
generalists who have a lot of people
that follow them because of their
messaging this is not a debate of we
would need two days to go through
scripture said this and what's your
rebuttal to this and what about this and
what about that we'll be here for days
two hours is not enough yeah
but if we were to judge a religion based
on what it produces
if
had the choice to choose a country and
you can't say none you have to choose
one if you were to say
you know a a countries we're starting a
country together what religion would we
want to start it with what religion
would best be a good religion to be
that's a fun question they want to start
a country with that's a really fun I'm
curious okay so let me answer the first
part I feel like I I left you hanging
because you ask a professor a question
he has like 40 minutes of Prelude to it
but to just get to it
I am not an atheist because I think
atheism is an intellectually vacuous
position
I think it's unsophisticated I don't
think it's smart an atheist a true
atheist right someone who is truly an
atheist is a materialist
a materialist believes that literally
nothing exists that nothing can exist
beyond my empirical experience of that
thing
that to me is the height of hubris and
absurdity right the idea that all that
exists is the material realm and nothing
Beyond it is just I would say even
scientifically absurd
now what is that other thing who knows
okay just let's just give it a word
because that's all the word God is it's
just a word it's not a thing it's a word
and like all words it has a thousand
connotations it represents a bunch of
things but in its simplest form let's
just say what we mean when we say God is
that which is beyond that which is
beyond the material realm the thing
the question then becomes can I access
that thing do I have the ability to
commune with it to communicate with it
to experience it in some way
and that's a personal thing I've
accessed it I've communicated with it
I've experienced it people who do yoga
people who climb mountains people who
surf and yes people who are Christians
or Jews or Muslims or Buddhists or
whatever can tell you a very similar
story yeah I'm not going to prove this
intellectually all I can tell you is
that there is something Beyond and I
have touched it I have felt it so then
the next question is do I want to know
it
was it enough that I climbed that
mountain and was like Wow and then I
went back home or do I want to know it
now
well if you want to know it
it so happens that there are a lot you
know thousands of years worth of systems
languages that's what really religion
it's all about it's just languages
languages are made up of symbols of and
metaphors that help you
experience communicate that experience
make sense of that experience
and you can pick any language you want
it is irrelevant what language you
choose just different symbols like
saying what's better French or German
what are you talking about they're both
expressing the exact same thing just
pick one
the Buddha very famously said
if you want to strike water you don't
dig six one foot Wells you dig one six
foot well
Islam is my six foot well
but the important thing that's hidden in
the Buddha's words there is that the
well is irrelevant the well is nothing
more than the means to get to the water
and guess what the water that you're
drinking from is the water that every
well is drinking from so pick a well
pick a well that works for you
in my case for a whole host of reasons
my culture my background my identity my
comfort Islam is my six foot well and
particularly Sufi Islam is my six foot
well it's the language that I use to
make sense of a thing that is
inexpressible
it's a it's a language I use to talk
about a thing that's impossible to talk
about
and it's a language that other people
understand so I can communicate with
them they get it we can talk about that
experience
but to say that I believe in the well is
stupid people who say I believe in
Christianity I believe in Islam I
believe in the Quran I believe in the
Torah are doing it wrong those are not
things to believe in they're your well
they're the thing that points you to the
thing to believe in
and so as someone who wants a deep and
meaningful
spiritual life who has experienced
Transcendence and wants to experience it
more and understand it more I've chosen
this particular well which is your risk
we've taken risk everybody's second The
Atheist takes a risk the Christian takes
a risk so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]